all right done painting my boat now last
thing to do is put the finishing touches
on it gonna paint name of the boat name
of the boat its Queen Rosa best lead dog
I've ever had all my whole dog yard
comes about out of her their
grandchildren her sons daughters here's
a wonderful dog and now that she's
passed I really want to honor her with
this because she always used to loves to
just ride up on this vowel right here
with me and she was my navigator and I
wish she was going out with me today
this dog Rosa she was the kind of dog
that affected the whole dog team I've
had about a hundred dogs probably since
I've started mushing dogs out of all
those dogs I just can't think of a dog
that was just more wonderful you know so
I couldn't imagine a better thing name
my boat after than my lead dog
she was real humble meet smile but when
it came to being on the trail and racing
she was out there to win oh man you know
no matter what the kind of trail I'd be
on with Rosa she wouldn't get you off
the trail she wouldn't get you in the
deep water she knew ice she knew how to
travel through storms I'm looking for
that in this dog yard and I can't even
sack white have that magical dog yet but
I think you know there's one in the
making out there for sure out of her
bloodline
just top-notch excellent dog but you
know the strong attributes of a sled dog
drive determination athleticism it's a
full package they're going to have tough
feet tough mind big hearts I mean these
are the best athletes in the world peace
I did ride sled dogs they travel a
thousand miles and eight days learning
13,000 calories a day I mean there's
nothing superior to and I did a ride
sled dog in my life here we go we got my
name for my boat gonna take it down to
the river with my dogs and put it in see
if the motor runs
you